it's personal what is now I mean well I
joined you know I drew on the labor
policy as a teenager in Dudley I was a
counselor there in my 20s I worked for
the party and for the labor government
authorities and I became an MP and I
government minister in my forties so
this has been my life this has been my
life our currently believe he's come to
this but I've got to be honest with
people I think that Jeremy Corbyn is
unfit to lead the Labour Party I think
he's certainly unfit to lead the country
the country faces a big choice there's
only two people who can be Prime
Minister on December the 13th and sadly
after look I've come to the conclusion
that it can't be Jeremy Corbyn and so on
that basis I think people should vote
for Boris Johnson and I think that this
is a choice that British people face and
I don't look I could just disappear off
back to Dudley never say a word keep
quiet
I think people in politics have got to
stand up and tell the truth
you gotta do what you think's right
however difficult it is why do you think
he's unfit to lead the country
I think that's he I think that it I
think he spent people are him and John
MacDonald spend their whole time in
politics working with defending
supporting all sorts of extremists in
some cases anti-semites and terrorists I
think at every opportunity he backs our
country's enemies whether that's the IRA
during the Troubles or calling Hamas and
Hezbollah his friends or parroting Putin
propaganda when the Russians send hit
men to murder people on the streets of
Britain I think that I don't think he
loves his country I don't think it's a
patriot I really don't and I've talked
about this long and hard but most
shamefully of all care you know
under his leadership a political party
with a proud record a long history
fighting for equality fighting racism
has become poisoned with until you eat
racism and it is a complete and utter
disgrace it's a complete disgrace and I
know what you know I know what Rebecca's
got a saying all that but there's no way
I've dealt with this and some of the
people are selecting as candidates even
over the last few days have said and
done things which are unacceptable and
Jeremy himself by the way has you know
seven done things which are anti-semitic
but why why nail your colours to the
mast and say vote conservative I mean
the Conservatives are not without guilt
when it comes to Islamophobia the
Prime Minister wrote an article which
caused significant issues a woman
wearing burkas who had letters thrown at
them when he described them as letter
boxes you know he's lied he's been
sacked twice for lying why would you
support him look I'm not touring and I'm
not gonna I'm not here to defend these
things and you know but you are saying
vote conservative but look there's a
choice there isn't the country faces a
choice the British people got in
scientists there are other parties
there's only two people can be Prime
Minister under some of the 13th Jeremy
Corbyn or Boris Johnson that is in the
end the choice okay look I can host over
this I mean this has been the toughest
thing I've had to find something about
to decide look I've been thinking about
this for a while decided finally well we
were delivering leaflets in Dudley over
the weekend while I was still I can ask
you know this decision you know I
decided over the last couple of days
sort of the weekend the beginning of the
week but look um I'm not gonna defend
what Boris Johnson said I wouldn't use
those words but to be fair to him he was
I think he was actually in an article
defending women's rights to wear the
burqa cos one what they wanted to do now
and this issue is Lama phobia the Tory
party of course he's got it out with of
course that's got to be dealt with but
it's look Sajid Javid knows right garni
then looking chase dilatory party by
racists which is what's happened to you
know Luciana Burch and all of Zellman
all the way they tried to target
Margaret Hodge and I think that there is
an issue it's the resolution and they're
working on it
come on there is an issue it's going up
believer well just on this story thing
there is an issue it's got to be dealt
with but I think when people compare it
with what something like the party it
minimizes the scandal this is an
institutional problem the Labour Party
the Labour Party is the first political
party in history to be subject to full
investigation body equality and human
rights commission when is completely
shameful
eight almost nine out of ten friends
Jewish community think jeremy corbyn's
anti-semitic
only six percent of Jewish people would
consider voting labor at this election
now he could ask yourself if a political
party has caused such huge offense and
distress to one of Britain's communities
whose side do you want whose so do you
want when it comes to racism I know a
lot responsibility is this is a basic
question of what's right and what's
wrong
I think this is a really fundamental
issue and if you're not going to stand
up and tell the truth and do what's
right
on something like racism what are you
gonna do it on what are you going to do
it on do you think that's right Tom
Watson standing on I mean look I talked
to Tom's a good guy he's a good friend
of mine I talk to him all the time I
think this you know I mean look if Tom
thought Jeremy Corbyn was fit to be
Prime Minister Dhoni if he thought there
was a prospect of a mystery he thought
he could be in a later cabinet as a
number two in a few weeks would you be
doing this I know from conversations of
how it's on how appalled hears about
what's happened with anti-semitism in
the Labor Party I know that what about
the timing of Trump you up with you and
Tom Watson doing what you're doing if
it's design is it designed to damage the
Labour Party Jonathan when did the most
vulnerable well I didn't discuss the
timing of Tom's announcement with him I
didn't do that I mean do I look is it
designed to damage the labor policy in
Jihad I mean
the I reported in my life you know but
the damage has been done
the damage has been done this party in
the Jeremy Corbyn is unfit to lead the
country and certainly I want to do
everything I can to stop Jeremy Corbyn
getting into another town I'll do this
with a really heavy heart that's the
most awful thing and there are friends
of mine you know who will feel betrayed
good friends of mine who are standing as
labour candidates are gonna feel
betrayed and upset but in politics you
know you've got to face up to tough
decisions and you've got to do what you
think is right and the country faces a
choice and this by the way this has
happened on our watch
right we have a responsibility for this
I could say something do with me and
walk away from it all
but in the end we've allowed this to
happen in the labour party and we've got
Toto sponsibility for it and I do not
want him to do to the country what I
think he's done to the right party
you're having this poisonous yeah I
think he's poisoned I think that I
possibly been poisoned with extremism
intolerance anti-semitism under his
leadership
why not stay and fight you know what
does it mean for centuries members of
the party who have rallied behind you
when you were there and behind Tom
Watson and now they're seeing you
jumping ship and
left behind well if I didn't leave the
Labour Party to join in the party I
didn't do that in February I left Sean a
spotlight on what's happening the party
and to demand other people step up and
do something about it and I've been
fighting about this and arguing about is
I think people said to me you don't stay
and fight I said where's the fine you
know you want me to saying fight you
better stop fighting I mean I didn't
walk away from this fight and I'm not
going to sort of I've formed a new
organization it's not political party
it's a cross party thing and involves
people manslaughter politics it's
mainstream UK org and as a campaign
against extremism on the far left and
hard right and we're going to be
standing up for decent mainstream
responsible values in British politics
and I'm going to be working with that
and doing everything I can to sort of
rid politics of extremism and racism
what would you say to other members of
the Labour Party and other Labour MPs
all that friends of mine I'm really
sorry about this you know and I had
every feeling I have furious and angry
they'll be there fighting elections and
I had tough that is your Anton doorsteps
and trying to persuade people you got me
doing this I mean you know but in the
end in the end I think Jeremy Corbyn
some fit to be our prime minister I
think it's a really important election
and I think voting for anybody other
than Jeremy Corbyn risks that happening
you know and how comfortably does it sit
with you finally and campaigning which
is what you're doing campaigning for the
Conservatives I mean look you know I'm
not a conservative this isn't where I
wanted to be so last thing I thought
could happened from a life in the light
party they're gonna be lifelong friends
money problem never speak to me it's not
about me that's right you're clearly
upset though I'm looking awesome massive
thing
it's a massive think I I could not
believe that would have come to this you
seem quite broken by it well you know
it's heartbreaking
I think what's something the lipo saw
break and I'll be honest about it you
know I think it's a disaster I think
it's a disaster fly party and it's a
disaster for our country and it's a
really difficult choice but decent
mainstream patriotic labour voters have
got us themselves whether Jeremy Corbyn
who supported terrorism supported
extremism backside country's enemies
well they can be trusted to lead it and
I just don't think he can I just don't
think he can and whatever what it was
all right fine I disagree with loads of
things the Conservative government's
done of course I do but in the end I
wouldn't say that they're in fit to run
the country I wouldn't say that and I do
think Jeremy Corbyn is and I've got to
be honest about it I've got to be honest
about it I mean thanks for joining us
thank you